لقد بكى عندما نزلت من
الأميرة الماسية ، كان الأمر صعبًا للغاية بالنسبة لي ،
كما قالت أثناء شكرها
لأعضاء الطاقم الدؤوبين في وقت سابق من الأسبوع ، قامت بتصوير
هذا الفيديو وهي تسير في مقصورتها في
انتظار نتائج
اختبارين لفيروس كورونا لكنهم عادوا
بالسلبية لأنهم  فعل لنحو 800
شخص آخرين أعطوا أساور خاصة لإثبات
ذلك ، وسُمح لهم جميعًا بالخروج يوم الأربعاء ،
ويقول المسؤولون إنهم لم تظهر عليهم أي أعراض
لأن المفرج عنهم حديثًا بدأوا في العودة إلى ديارهم
والمنزل حيث قابلنا يوكي شخصيًا على بعد
30 دقيقة فقط بالسيارة من السفينة  لقد
أرادت أن تقابل في الخارج ، إنها
تتذكرها بشكل سلبي لكنها كانت قلقة من أنها
ستمرضنا بشكل جيد لسبب ما أنا
مصاب بالفيروس بالفعل ، قالت إنني لا أريد أن
أكون الشخص الذي يصيب الآخرين
عندما بدأ الحجر الصحي ، لقد وضعت الكثير من
الثقة في  قالت السلطات الصحية اليابانية
إن أفضل طريقة للحفاظ على
سلامة الجميع هي إبقاء الأشخاص في الحجر الصحي في
غرفهم ، ومع استمرار ارتفاع عدد الحالات ،
شعرت يوكي بالتوتر ، وهي تقول إن العدد
كان 60 70 9 يوميًا.  9 إصابات جديدة كنا
خائفين من مدى قوة هذا يقول مسؤولو الصحة الأمريكيون
إن الحجر الصحي ربما
لم يكن كافياً لوقف انتشار الفيروسات ،
تعترف السلطات اليابانية بعدم وجود حجر صحي
مثالي بنسبة مائة بالمائة ، لكن هذا
كان ولا يزال الخيار الأفضل وأن معظم
إن لم يكن الكل  تم
التعاقد مع إصابات جديدة قبل بدء الحجر الصحي ، ويشكك
بعض الركاب والخبراء الخارجيين في
أنه يوم الأربعاء مع نزول الناس ، كانت
رئيسة رحلات Princess Cruises ،
جان شوارتز ، هناك لتحية أولئك
المحظوظين بما يكفي لمغادرتها.
لا أعتقد أن الحجر الصحي
عمل أشخاصًا آخرين كانوا قلقين من أنه
نظرًا لأن الطاقم لم يكن في الحجر الصحي
الذي يمكن أن يكون له تأثير على
سلامتهم ، فماذا تقول لتلك المخاوف
خاصةً بالنظر إلى أنه لا
يزال هناك أشخاص على متن السفينة تعرفهم أعتقد
أن العملية بأكملها  من منظور طبي
وصحي عام تم إدارته من
قبل وزارة هي اليابانية  ما
يمكنني قوله اليوم هو أنه عندما نزلنا من
الطائرة ، فقد ثبتت إصابته بالفيروس
التاجي ، قالت شوارتز إنها عملت
عن كثب مع السلطات الصحية اليابانية
وشكرتها على جهودهم حتى
كما شعرت لأولئك الذين كانوا على متنها ، فهذا
وضع غير مسبوق ، أعني أنه لا أحد
يذهب في إجازة  يعتقد أنه
سيتم إخطارهم في الأيام الأخيرة
بأنهم حصلوا على تمديد لمدة 14 يومًا
ولن يُسمح لهم
بالعيش ومغادرة مقصورتهم حتى تنفطر قلوبنا
لكل شخص عانى من
هذا الموقف.
استمر في ليلة الأربعاء هذا
الفيديو من أسترالية سجلت
مسيرتها إلى الحرية على بعد 30 دقيقة فقط.
يوكي سعيد بالعودة إلى المنزل ولكن ما زلت مرهقًا
سأظل قلقة حتى
ينتهي تفشي المرض
.  فوق أنهار مات
سي إن إن يوكوهاما اليابان